today we're going to have a look at the
exponential form of a complex number
now this little pearl of mathematics is
something we introduced
last lesson but you might recall that we
actually did sort of an informal proof
and
um it's kind of what we refer to as a
bit hand wavy there were some bits where
it was kind of like oh
just trust me and um you'll see why this
is going to make sense in the end but
if you're an inquisitive person you
might be thinking i'm not 100 sure or
100 convinced
that all of the logic in the argument
was uh completely watertight and that's
because it was
an informal proof we still ended at the
right result
but it was required a little bit of
trust in order to get to the end of it
what i'm going to do today is what we
call a rigorous proof
that will land us on the exponential
form of a complex number as you've
already encountered
but to do that we're going to have to go
this in long forms that's why we're
going to take our time through here and
you can see i've got this outline
that we're going to march through for
starters i'm going to establish
there is some knowledge that you need to
come into
uh this proof there's some foundational
stuff we're going to build upon
this is one of the best things about
mathematics things don't come out of
thin air
we take theorems and properties and
characteristics of numbers and shapes
and we develop those
slowly over time like a big pyramid and
then we can reach these really amazing
heights
by building on some very strong
foundations so i'm going to make sure we
cover like what things do you need to
know
to understand this proof fully i'm going
to introduce a new
idea to you uh something which is
strictly speaking
not something you have to know about but
it's a very handy idea
um called a field and we're going to
that's going to lead into
the formal proof of euler's formula
that's what we did informally last time
point three that formal proof is going
to take the bulk of our time
and probably the bulk of your mental
effort and then finally
we're going to conclude i really should
have called that conclusion but i wanted
everything to start with an
f so i just called it finish all right
so
if you're ready to go and uh you know
you've got you've got a glass of water
maybe something to eat there
then buckle in and we're gonna have a go
so to start with
foundational knowledge there are three
key ideas
that you really need to have down pat in
order to understand everything
here so the first one which you might
recall from last time when we had a look
at the informal proof
is you need to know how to differentiate
the basic trigonometric
functions so those being sine x
and cos x i'll put that down here
now we're going to need that i'm going
to kind of assume that
the results for those namely that the
derivative of sine x it becomes
cos x and the derivative of cos x
becomes
negative sine x maybe i'll put those in
other colors just so you
see that they're not actually just the
same thing we are going to
i'm just going to assume them as as
taken results if you want
i'll talk about later if you're some
yeah you're not up to that yet that's
okay
we'll talk about how you can prove that
for yourself the second thing
which you have absolutely covered in
some detail but you're going to keep on
doing in the next
12 months of the course is the chain
rule or the function of a function rule
so
this again is something i'm going to be
using quite a lot
and because i'm going to be using it a
lot you have to be
not just something like that you know
but you have to be
fluent in it you have to see oh i see
where the function is on the outside i
see where the function is on the inside
and then deal with them quite
comfortably and then the newest idea
that's involved
in this that we're going to rely on is
something called integration
which is for the intents and purposes of
what going we're going to do today
it's the opposite of differentiation so
sometimes it's analogous to this process
called
anti-differentiation they are slightly
different you'll discover why a little
bit later on
but that's something we're going to do
right toward the end of the proof
now one of the tricky things about this
is that like you may be thinking
why am i using some bits and pieces of
mathematics that i am familiar with some
i'm less familiar with
now so that we can use this result well
the answer
is because you're studying mathematics
advanced extension one extension two
and they are strictly speaking separate
courses with separate
syllabuses however for me one of the
most beautiful things about them is how
nicely they
interweave they're connected syllabuses
connected curriculums connected stories
as it were so they kind of overlap and
touch each other
and the order in which you learn them
because they all interact with each
other interface
um can complicate things sometimes so
i'm going to assure you that by the end
of the course you will have met
all of these ideas you'll be very
comfortable with them at least that's
the goal
however in the meantime if you're like
well i'm not there yet and i still don't
really get this or
maybe you're learning this at a
different point you just want to revise
these ideas
so this proof makes sense to you then
i've got a bunch of videos about all of
these so
when it comes to differentiating the
trigonometric functions sine cos
we don't need tan for this but it just
sort of comes along for the ride
you can have a look at my videos on the
calculus of trig functions
for the chain rule um that's something
which you've been using for a little
while but only probably in polynomials
depending on where you are in the course
at the moment
so the basic idea though it applies to
oh you probably have done exponential
functions as well maybe logs
but we're going to be using with
trigonometric functions so you can have
a look at those
and then for integration it is a massive
big idea
so if you want to have a look at those
again plenty of videos
about that but you will discover in the
next few weeks and months
okay so this is the foundational
knowledge this is what you've got to
have understood
i will point out because um sort of the
newest idea to you is this uh
integration this anti-differentiation
idea
when we get to it in the course of this
proof i will sort of
try to explain in a way that even if you
don't have any of the big theory like
you haven't watched these videos or you
haven't learned it
um before um you will still be able to
follow along we'll base it on our
understanding of just
regular differentiation okay so that was
point one
foundational knowledge let's now
introduce this idea what we call a
field now what i mean by fields i'm not
talking about grassy
fields i'm talking actually about a kind
of mathematical object
that you already know about you just
haven't called them fields
let me just delete this so i can get
them out of the way when we started
in the topic of complex numbers we
talked about the fact that there are
different kinds
of numbers and we would call these you
know sets the set of natural numbers or
counting numbers right
this is you know one two three four five
um some people include zero in that but
it doesn't matter all that much
and uh then we quickly said you know
from natural numbers you can develop all
kinds of other
numbers for example we say there's the
integers right
we extend this to include the the
negative numbers right so not only do
you have 1
2 3 and so on and 0. but you also have
going in the opposite
direction so you've got negative 1
negative 2
and so on now the important thing i want
to get to
and this idea of fields is that um
fields are
these kinds of collections of of numbers
and
the important thing about them is that
you know particular fields will sort of
uh lead you out into other fields if
you're like they're kind of connected
right so
what i mean by that is the field of
natural numbers okay one two three and
and so on
it uh sort of i was gonna say natural a
natural consequence of the natural
numbers
is that you end up with the integers if
you just think about regular operations
like uh subtraction for example if you
only have addition
of natural numbers then you can only if
you add up any two or three or however
many natural numbers you like you'll get
another natural number but
as soon as you allow subtraction you
sort of break into
the field of integers right just think
about this if you did
three take away one you'd still be in
the natural number field you'd get
two but as soon as you do one take away
three
that the answer to that uh expression
doesn't have a solution
within the natural number field you're
like that's that's why young children
will say you can't do
one take away three because their only
concept for
um for subtraction is taking a
a smaller number away from a bigger
number but once you do the reverse
you're like oh
i need other numbers to explain what's
going on here so we would say negative 2
right so what this means is that the
field of natural numbers
is what we call open um it sort of opens
out into other fields like like the
field of integers right
and um it sort of opens out into other
fields as well like for example this q
you might remember
this stands for the rational numbers and
uh the rational numbers are what come
from not addition or subtraction but
from
division so let me just extend this a
little further if i go back to the
natural numbers
let's go 5 6. that'll that might do me
for now
if i do 6 divided by 3
i will still stay within the field of
natural numbers right
you just get 2. but if i do 6 divided by
5
then none of these is the answer to that
question so
6 divided by 5 it becomes a rational
number it's in a different field so you
can see
the natural numbers open out into here
and you can keep on going right when you
start thinking about
i've actually missed one here after the
rational numbers you could talk about
say the irrational
numbers so pop one over the top there so
the irrational numbers
if we start thinking about other
operations right if we start thinking
about not just addition subtraction
multiplication division if we start to
think about
square roots for example which really
come from using these operations and
writing equations right so if i wrote an
equation like x
squared minus 4 equals 0.
this equation here i actually should put
it up over here puts me in the
integer number field here right because
the solutions would be
plus or minus 2. but if i wrote an
equation like this x squared minus
5 i'm still using the same familiar
tools addition subtraction
multiplication division
exponentiation that's what gives me this
index up here but now
um my answers to this are not going to
be natural they're not going to be
integers they're not going to be
rational
they're going to be you're going to get
plus or minus the square root of 5 here
so you get an irrational number
right so you can see these fields they
keep on opening out right
um you can then go to the real numbers
uh you can go even broader than this
so the whole idea here is that these
fields here
all open right from these fields you can
get into
other fields but and this is what's kind
of special about complex numbers
even though there are other kinds of
numbers the field of complex numbers
is what we call and i'll put this in
another color just to highlight it right
it's what we call
algebraically closed it's not open
using the tools of algebra the
operations that i was just
naming before within arithmetic using
those tools
you you can't get from the complex
numbers to other kinds
of numbers it's a closed field it's it's
like you're sort of uh
fenced in right no matter what ways you
combine
uh you know the real and imaginary parts
you can write some weird and wacky
equations like this you can use limits
you can use all kinds of things
you'll never escape um the field of
complex numbers
is algebraically closed